we happen to be doing a story about you
know how bad it gets with stars um did
it get to the point where people were
going through your trash and that sort
of a thing to you know dig up dirt on
you or
yeah apparently for a little while there
you know
there was a time when people
whoever they were were sort of
fascinated with what what i might be
throwing away
you know into the garbage can
it just happens i don't know i mean
i don't know i mean i've never really
been fascinated with anyone's
trash before but
some people you know what can you do
do you know what they were looking for
looking for notes or things about your
personality or something or
adult diapers maybe i don't know
i'm not sure what they were looking for
um
but you know what's real weird about
that the whole the sort of
like the the
how the media thing gets sort of
stretched out into this really absurd
kind of surreal thing is
you know like i said you know you're an
actor and you're trying to do your job
you know there's a
ton of them out there who are trying to
just kind of do their job get by and do
the best they can make some money
whatever
and then suddenly you reach a certain
level in your career
and
this kind of
this sort of wheel starts spinning about
your past and your future and your
present and who are you with last night
and what club and this
and like you know how many people you've
you know quite possibly bumped uglies
with or something you know
it's like
suddenly this thing starts happening it
becomes no it doesn't become it's not
about the work anymore it's not about
films it's not about you know it becomes
this kind of showboat thing
this sort of society of ambulance
chasers
who uh
who are fascinated with uh
you know
your personal life
or uh
you know
like what's inside your brain and things
like that and to me that's that's really
frightening because
i mean there's only i mean there's only
a couple of actors that i can think of
that i that that
i would be fascinated to find out what
what their thoughts are marlon brando is
one of them
i mean he's obviously like an amazing
amazing actor and he's
possibly the greatest but
what fascinates me about marlon brando
is
his brain and his thoughts
you know
but
i mean to be to become fascinated with
the personal life
or the or the thoughts and opinions of a
person
who
pretends for living
who lies for money
is beyond me
so what do you do then how do you
deal with all this stuff lay low
just kind of lay low i don't you know
i'm not a real uh
uh function oriented
person i i don't uh i don't do well
at functions or
you know like the the
hollywood party scene
i just kind of uh
i don't uh
go there so much i just kind of stay
home you know or wander a bit tell us
about your favorite cigars your
fascination why is this something that
is part of you well you know what i i'm
a
i'm a smoker
it's not a popular thing to be in 1993 i
smoke
but uh
i don't know cigars somehow just
they seem it's a great
it's as soon as you light it it's sort
of somehow you instantly relax it's just
i don't know what it is
um
my favorite cigars i can't say there's
so many great ones i have you know
there's some real nice cuban cigars
it's not it's not a fault it's not like
a it's a real thing you know when people
say oh cuban cigars the finest
you think is look cigars cigar tobacco's
tobacco no it's raw
cumin cigars
are the stuff
um
a favorite maybe you know maybe uh
cohiba lancero
that's kind of a thing that was castro's
cigar that's that was his favorite cigar
before he quit
to people who don't smoke what would you
liken cigar smoking that that feeling
too is it like a fine wine or
how would you just yeah maybe like
depending on the cigar you're smoking
would be uh
comparing it to maybe
a warm
cognac you know
just something like that suddenly
everything starts to just kind of calm
down and just sort of
sort of sink into the old lazy boy
how did you get into the cigars did
somebody introduce you or was it because
if someone walked up to me and handed me
a rolled up pair of socks i would
probably smoke it
i'm i'm one of the few and the proud
smokers who really love smoke i
if i
if i could have another mouth grafted
onto my face to smoke more i would do it
i have lung power from
i i
the one gift i have in this world is i
have incredibly strong
sometimes i smoke two three cigarettes
at a time
i can hear the american cancer society
bones ringing right now the publicists
are going get this wow you don't have to
use it i mean it's just sort of there
you're being honest you know yeah
unfortunately i'm in you know a
big smoker
oh yeah
[Music]
you